j'ai envie que ma bête comment ça va eh
ben ça va bien patrice vous savez moi je
suis piquée par un virus c'est le virus
du salat bien donc ça va bien tout le
dos ça va bien ça va bien et vous êtes
prêt pour un débouché à oreille oui on
va parler de quoi on va parler d'un
homme absolument exceptionnel qui
s'appelle auguste escoffier auguste
escoffier grand grand grand chef six
bocuse est incontestablement le
cuisinier du siècle on peut considérer
qu escoffier est probablement le
cuisinier de tous les temps il est
cuisinier son père et maréchal ferrant
il fait ses apprentissages dans sa
région c'est quoi la région on est dans
l'auvergne et andré rhin et dans un
vernir absolument risque et donc mais il
va partout auguste escoffier et
notamment à londres l'angleterre est à
l'origine à cette période on est au
début du 19e siècle des grands palaces
pourquoi à londres pourquoi et bien
parce que c'est en angleterre que se
développe d'abord les chemins de fer et
là le développement des chemins de fer
va également permettre le développement
des grands palaces en occident en europe
et escoffier fait une rencontre
extraordinaire avec un homme connu
aujourd'hui parce que son nom reste
place vendôme série tz et figurez-vous
que escoffier après avoir était le grand
chef du savon y real on était le palace
nous imposant aux nouveaux
arrivés à paris au ritz avec donc son
associé puisqu'il était associé à la
mérite et il a inventé escoffier
plusieurs choses extrêmement importantes
premièrement les brigades de cuisine
c'est lui qui a mis en place toute
l'organisation des grandes cuisines dans
les grands restaurants de plage reste
toujours absolument et donc escoffier a
également été celui qui a
mis en place les modèles de la
gastronomie française
jusqu'à lui on était dans des recettes
plutôt empirique 1 où il y avait des
grands cuisiniers bien entendu mais sur
des cuisines de coeur avec les produits
du terroir escoffier a fait en sorte que
tout cela soit
répertoriée il est l'inventeur de ce
qu'on appelle la fiche technique
aujourd'hui vient entre scientifiques et
si on peut dire ça l'a fait alors il a
été d'ailleurs et c'est important de le
signaler parmi ceux qui ont essayé de
défendre les droits d'auteur en cuisine
il n'y a pas réussi et puis il a été
celui aussi qui a
retiré des de la cuisine de l'ancien
temps les farines toutes ces choses un
peu lourde et donc il a évidemment à
l'époque était suivi dans son exemple
par beaucoup de grands chefs et donc les
fiches techniques qui ont suivi
également leur évolution et puis toutes
les grande cuisine de palace dans le
monde se sont dotés de ces brigades et
rades et prendre conseil auprès de l'ust
escoffier pour créer tout ça donc voilà
c'est le grand créateur de la cuisine
moderne on peut dire ça absolument il
s'appelle comment est ce que j ai
scoffier merci beaucoup à vous ces gens
luttent voilà jean luc granet gauche est
reparti vers ses prochains très vite